we've been looking at travelers a bit
recently right and we've been so far
singing the praises of approaching
things and thinking through things
parametric please like using this guy to
AP AP squared or 288 e squared or 2 and
Q and Q squared or equina P and all of
the strengths and insights that you gain
from saying things in that way okay but
that doesn't mean that thinking about
things without the tremor not just with
the X&Y is just thinking of Cartesian
turns that doesn't mean there's nothing
together in fact one of the most
interesting results which we get in this
course comes from distorted back to its
old way of thinking older way of giving
and the given in terms of X's and Y's so
here's a simple question and we don't
need any parameters or anything to give
this a go so we're gonna try it
we're going to generalize from there
like for an unknown parabola and unknown
point and then following on from there
tomorrow is where we're going to finish
and I'll show you one of the most
interesting results in the whole course
so how would you tackle it especially
there are plenty of tools of your
disposal won't be your first step to the
other Society okay good so x squared
equals 4y this is kind of written in
like locusts for right that you can see
the M what's the focal length of this
parabola just hanging off it's gonna be
one right because for any Y a must be
one in this place okay but in order to
work with it in cartesian terms the
difference here and that kind of thing I
want Y to be the subject because then I
can get dy/dx etc so I'm going to write
this and from there thank you
differentiate what's the derivative
Newsday okay excellent I know that twos
gonna come out the front it's gonna
cancel Polly with the full so I just yet
and you notice I wrote dy/dx not just
equals okay right that's good what am I
gonna do with this derivative
yeah the x-coordinate of the point that
you want to find the tangent
okay excellent
so I know this is the gradient at any
point on the parabola but I want the
specific one here so I'll say at x
equals two I can find I can evaluate my
derivative and that gives me one it's a
nice simple example okay so now I have
all the pieces I need right like in
order to get the equation of a line I
have a points I have a great yet so I'm
going to chuck it into a great this is
not complicated let's give this a quick
shot so I've got Y minus y1 which is one
equals and the gradient which is one
outside of X take wait just a teeny
little bit of simplifying we're gonna
add one to both sides which leaves me
with X so far so good
no sweat off my back that's happy you
can check it out you can really simply
graph it it's not complicated no big
deal
I want to generalize from this right
this is for a specific parabola at a
specific point okay so if we have some
kind of general problem right so this is
generalizing okay
I want to come up with like a formula
for this kind of thing just like we have
the equation of a line with a given
gradient and through a given point can I
do some generalization to have like a an
equivalent Y minus y1 equals M outside
it X minus x1 for this problem okay
so generally speaking I would say 4x
squared equals or a Y so this could be
any problem right and let's begin for it
ok so a point if I say it's anywhere we
might call that x coordinate x1 now it
wouldn't be that unusual to call this
next point why I was write x1 y1 but as
you'll see right echo 2 y1 are not
really two separate numbers are they
right they are linked together through
this equation
and we're gonna take advantage of that
in a second I'm gonna go through much
the same steps but I'm just gonna have
more abstract stuff in there more
algebra because I don't know what any of
these numbers are okay so I'm gonna make
Y the subject just like I did before
okay so I'm gonna get a driven and
another I had eight ones one here right
equals one and that's really down the
bottom so this is actually gonna be X on
today are you satisfied with that now I
want this at a particular point namely
x1 y1 right so at that point at x equals
x1 right so that's a value now what is
the derivative equal to do you want any
X is equal to because our products 1
yeah there's nothing I can really do to
this thing
like I can't simplify any things I
didn't know anything here okay so that's
good so now I can pop this into the same
kind of full my head before right y
minus y1 equals and what's migrating
here x1 onto outside off X minus x1
hmm okay now how would you rewrite this
how would you make this a bit simpler
there's a few different ways have a guy
I'll give you a second to catch up here
something you're still writing introduce
you there's a few different things
present we can make it so that you're
grading exactly the great news
how would you know I've given you forms
before and said okay I want you to get
in this particular form
I'm leaving the door open like this is
what we started how would you write this
to maximise the simplicity that you can
get out of this I'm sure if you play
with it a little bit that's okay
let me rehearse where most of you are -
I think most people see probably
multiplying by 2a that's probably a good
idea because they don't get rid of
fractions right so most of you have
something like this - a y -2 a y1 and on
the right hand side I can expand this as
well I've got an X X 1 there and I've
got X 1 multiplied by itself in there
okay now from this point it's not really
that clear what to do like there are no
more like terms there's not much point
factorizing because I just expanded and
I could factorize but that just sends me
back where I came from okay
remember I said to you okay that x1 and
y1 they are three numbers but they
linked they are late they are linked
through with my record of math isn't it
these two are linked through this
equation what that means is for instance
since this point should is on this
parabola right it satisfies this right
like if I put these numbers in here it
should be a true statement so if all
they do is just put those in right I can
write x1 squared that's my x value
equals full a why what do you agree with
that like what a breeze just put that
point which is on the parabola
I'm putting it into the equation for the
problem now the reason why this is
useful is because I have an x 1 square
yard and I have some a Y ones over here
so things are going to get simpler for
me this thing which sort of you like
what can I do with this well you can get
rid of it
so my next line I'm gonna write it up
here I've got 2
it's to a why one that's gonna simplify
in a second equals x x-1 - full a y be
happy with that
alright now I only need to do a little
bit of shimmying to this to get it into
a nice spot I'll collect all of these
light tones these guys I guess I'll add
for a Y 1 to both sides and will give me
this that's alright that's looking
pretty simple right I'm gonna do one
more thing to it because it looks like I
should keep the Y's together
why is it amiss but this X x1 I'll make
that means he's made the subject and now
I'm going to factorize because this is
helpful right this this you can put a
big box around this I didn't have my red
this is our generalization right after
all of this work of differentiating
jamming all together and trying to make
it as simple as we can get rid of like
these awkward terms in here this is
really elegant all your need is the
coordinates of the point and this focal
length you it's more than me right by
using these it even takes out an
equation I don't need to differentiate I
can just go straight here watch let's
give this a go that was the question we
started with right and you already told
me right in the beginning that a is
equal to 1
yes let's just try it out see what
happens X X 1 1 X 1 again equals to x 1
y plus 1 okay I've got a 2 down 2 to
their right and bam x equals y plus 1
make Y the subjects it just falls out
like how do you even made it to work you
just need to substitute a little bit and
Bob's your uncle
okay now speed and efficiency are one of
the strengths of this equation here
right this is the equation
the tension in Cartesian form if you
like you can put it next to your x
equals sorry y equals px minus ap
squared which is your parametric form of
the same thing okay but you can see it
feeds in quite different information
there's no parameter Z so that's how you
remember this is not the parametric form
okay now like I said speed and
efficiency are one of the good things
about this but there's even more cool
stuff and we'll find out about it
tomorrow